hi this is Ted bellacor with reason TV
today i'll be speaking with bill simon
in 2002 simon won the Republican primary
for California's gubernatorial race
before losing to gray davis in the
general election as he did for rudy
giuliani's 2008 presidential campaign
Simon often serves as policy guru two
high-profile candidates and how about
this sometimes he paddles out with
surfing legend Laird Hamilton okay as a
guy who grew up in San Diego I can't
help but be jealous about your surfing
buddy I can't say the surfing buddy i
will say that we've gone surfing
together a couple times and today we did
will stand up paddling and i had never
tried it before and he's a great guy
he's a great example he's like rudy
today you know he's a great leader on
the morning of September 11 2001 you
were having breakfast with Rudy Giuliani
when the World Trade Center was attacked
how did he respond what was that like he
responded by saying to me bill you know
I've gotta run now we have been talking
about my run for office and he said
maybe we can have a drink later and so
he he was very efficient he hopped in
the car himself went right down to the
scene and that's the kind of Mary was
that's the kind of leader he is so he
was he's the best leader I've never seen
in my lifetime you were top policy
advisor for the Giuliani presidential
campaign and that seems to be par for
the course for you in a lot of ways you
use you seem to have this role as sort
of the professor of ideas of the
candidates of people favoring limited
government how did you how did that role
come about when Rudy started gearing up
to run for president you know I said to
my love to help you and he said gray
said would you like to do and so what
what I really would like to do is ruin
your policy operation and I could see he
was kind of hmm yeah sure you know I
think he probably figured big Lauren
chomping at the dope it would match up
with the vet for that one so we did a
series of policy briefings for him they
came to call that Simon University and
and so that was some I don't know how
some things happening in life you don't
know how it happened and so I I don't
know they call that side of the
university and still do apparently
obviously the Republicans are trying to
regroup and find their way I'll ask you
maybe the the rude Iran or MIT question
when he when he looked the future of the
Republican Party what sort of type do
you see as as being the sort of
candidate that they're going to go
toward will be Rudy Giuliani typed more
socially liberal very big on
anti-terrorism issues would it be the
Ron Paul type more libertarian a dove
and foreign policy the mitt romney type
conservative all around what do you
think the future holds you know i think
that whoever is a good leader is going
to win the Republican nomination i I
think if there was somebody out there
that was a good leader and was a
conservative they might have you know
the best chance but I don't necessarily
think that that's the be all and end all
either because so much of it is the
person but if somebody is a strong
leader I think at the end of the day
they get the nod because you know just
like Reagan you had the Reagan Democrats
you know why why did they vote for
Reagan not because they ain't greed with
him he was a leader and that's why you
build these coalition's of people that
will support you that maybe feel that
you're a leader maybe they feel you
won't embarrass them you know I think
that's why I got so close to gray davis
you know the registration difference is
12 in california or was when i read i
lost by four and so you'd say well he
beat spread by eight you know at Las
Vegas that that's good but in politics
you know you still lose but having beat
the spread you say well how come he beat
the spread there must be somebody out
there that's a registered Democrat that
vote
for why was that well most likely it's
because I wasn't I wasn't scary to them
one area where things are looking up
here in Los Angeles LAUSD isn't really
thought of as a beacon of innovation and
yet they go and do this wild thing where
they open up roughly 250 schools to
competition its growth at the charter
schools or other private operators can
take over failing public schools what's
your take on that fantastic fantastic
these charter schools I have incredible
college admissions and that's obviously
one judge and you know I think it's
fantastic that a third of LAUSD is going
to in effect become charter and I'm
going to do everything I can to help do
you see this as as the just the
beginning and maybe we're turning the
tide against the public school monopoly
do you see this as spread I mean if it
happens if it happened in LA New York it
can happen anywhere right it's true
that's true I you know I'd say this I
would never underestimate the unions you
know for the union's education is not
about teaching children it's about a
jobs program for their members the
current fiscal crisis in California
there's still a lot of disagreement
about what actually caused this
near-death experience what do you think
caused it we spent more than we took in
that simple that's simple you know if
you go back 20 years roughly basically
expenses grew at five point nine percent
revenues grew at five point six percent
now it doesn't sound like a big spread
but over 20 years it adds up so I'll
just talk about prop 13 the national
recession the two-thirds rule that's
you're not buying it well you know those
those are all things that you know you
can talk about and they would contribute
you know to the size of the deficit but
the fact that we have a big deficit is
principally because we spent more than
we took in and when you on an individual
level you hear a lot about people having
a rock bottom moment they they go in a
big vendor or something that hit rock
bottom but then it's a learning
experience California sort of went
through that have we learned anything
well I think in that area if you want
talk about hitting bottom you know some
people hit bottom a number of times and
I think California I think could be
likened to someone who relapses with
some frequency and the Schwarzenegger
tail is a tragic wanted it looked so
good at the beginning he was talking
about cutting taxes cutting spending he
got in office and did exactly the
opposite what happened well I think he
tried to fight too many battles I think
he changed his mind about a couple of
things and I think he tried to get too
much done instead of focusing like a
laser on just a handful of things i
would have liked it if budget have been
one but even if it wasn't as a result he
hasn't gotten a lot done because he was
like that that butterfly going from
buttercup to buttercup and at the end of
the day does not a lot to show
you